hi I'm Jeff Kaplan and today we'll be
doing overwatch support this question
comes to us from nudes
why is Genji such a cool dude why
explain if you were a cyborg ninja
wouldn't you be a cool dude too
it's not like he's an accountant or he
works at the supermarket he is a cyborg
ninja this one is from judge' jameson is
it ever going to be revealed exactly
what junk rats treasure is at some point
it will be revealed I think the better
question to ask is is it junk rats
treasure in the first place just leave
you with a little hint there we have a
question here from blade Mitchell how
come over watch competitive isn't placed
based on individual skill instead of
win-loss doing a competitive matchmaking
system is actually quite complicated in
a game like hearthstone we're judging
one versus one performance so it's very
easy to decide what you as an individual
contributed in a hearthstone match
versus your opponent in a game of
overwatch you've got six players on your
side and six players on the other side
and you're basically one small part of
the fraction so we have to look at a
much bigger picture when it comes to
breaking down your individual
performance and your contribution to the
overall outcome of that competitive
match now there's a lot of complicated
things we do under the hood but at the
end of the day whether your team won or
lost is still the best indicator of a
team's success or failure and your
contribution to that so I know it
doesn't always seem super fair but it's
the Feres way we have of judging comrade
brennan writes to us why is nerfing
reaper not a thing actually if you
listen to a lot of our community they've
been talking about buffing Reaper so it
really depends on the skill level that
you're playing at the types of
compositions that you're seeing and
whether or not you have a highly skilled
Reaper player playing against you or
with you that sort of forms your opinion
of whether Reaper should be buffed or
nerfed but at this time we think Reaper
is in a pretty good place pkmn mastered
Jarrod I'm assuming that's Pokemon
master I hope it is why is Widowmaker
blue
so Widowmaker really has a tragic arc
and it's interesting when you think
about the the trials that she's been
through so she was originally married to
an overwatch operative and she was
brainwashed
and used to assassinate her own husband
this is absolutely tragic story and
after that she was really you know
deprogrammed to become a talent agent
and then later they did all sorts of
freaky experiments with her to slow her
heart rate down to make her the amazing
sniper that she is but the end result is
at her skin turn blue and she's actually
a little bit numb in more than one way
agent bro tastic writes us anyone has
any ideas on how to make your FPS much
higher rip my gameplay there's a lot of
things you can do to make your FPS
higher your video card is one of the key
components to performance your hard disk
speed your CPU now if you want to make
software adjustments within overwatch I
recommend looking at things like world
scale looking at what resolution you're
playing in I would highly recommend
playing in full-screen and generally
turning things down then checking the
game without turning everything down all
at once because then you won't know
what's yielding that FPS back to you
from Dobie Wolff seriously why is
Reinhardt able to still move at full
speed while swinging his hammer awhile
IRISA and Deva slow down to shoot
Reinhardt is defined by two main
functions to his character one is that
glorious barrier to protect his
teammates and to create a front and the
other is the hammer now Reinhardt
doesn't have a lot of ranged capability
he has fire strike which is a great
range attack and does a lot of damage
but it's on a very long cooldown besides
his charge ability which really isn't
meant for Reinhardt to use as mobility
Reinhardt only has base movement speed
to get around so we felt like the
engagement range being rather short on
the hammer it would have been an extra
detriment to slow Reinhardt down while
he was swinging that hammer from undead
arena what do I do
if in my first two placement matches we
get someone afk will they be punished
I'm really upset if somebody is afk
in a placement match we've added
functionality on PC to report these
players where you can say they're being
inactive right now and we have a whole
customer support and hacks and risk
department here at Blizzard that looks
at people who have egregious amounts of
reports now on console the report
functionality is coming soon in the
meantime you can use the native
reporting features of the Xbox and the
PlayStation to report bad behavior
through the Sony and Microsoft channels
from Jess what is a Tobel steen and why
is Aria always going for it Tobel scene
is a made-up word those of us on the
development team have been saying it
since we first got the voice recordings
in and the players have picked up on
saying this as well when she she casts
her graviton surge it sounds like she's
saying something about the Tobal steam
well this is just us in our ignorance
not understanding the Russian language
but she's saying a gonpa got toes nasty
and I did pronounce that very poorly but
what that means in Russian is fire at
will so there you have it we all call it
the Tobel steam though now from space
Jess I know almost zero overwatch lore
why is Reaper just standing there
creeping on a family in the shadows like
a 15 year old goth there's a lot more
that's going to come out about Reaper
this is something that we don't want to
reveal immediately but it is a story
we're very compelled to tell overtime
from midnight and beyond serious
question what's the point of alternate
costumes in a game like overwatch when
you can't even see your character when
you play so when we were first making
this game we were very committed to
making the game in first-person
now we also knew we were going to have a
rich cast of characters that we wanted
you to identify with and fall in love
with and part of that was providing cool
skins like the costumes that you
mentioned for the characters so what
we've tried to do to solve this problem
is show your character in all its glory
in as many places as possible so for
example when you log into the game on
the front menu most of your characters
are standing there in really big form
when you go to hero select we show a
giant version of your character so you
can really get a sense of it and lastly
seeing
other people and seeing their skins and
realizing how cool they are really goes
a long way to from pretzels why is
symmetric class and not defense class I
have seriously always wondered this when
we originally added the whole class
system where we added roles to overwatch
we did it primarily for new players who
were first approaching the game they
would see this big list of 20-some
characters and have no idea which
character they should even play so we
did it as an easy way for players to
digest what the characters may or may
not be about and I don't want to say it
was arbitrary who we put into what
category I mean we did put a lot of
thought against it but there wasn't a
lot of rigid gameplay mechanics behind
what role they were in you know we
honestly talked about Torbjorn being in
support at one point characters that
could bring some utility to the
battlefield that wasn't necessarily just
shooting at people she could easily be
in the defense class I don't know if we
did that today if it would actually
change anything in overwatch okay for
xerton from a lore perspective how do
use in Yoda's discord and harmony orbs
work biotech for latter maybe but the
former we've talked a lot about this we
have a lead writer by the name of
Michael Chu and people have asked this
about Reaper in some cases where they
ask you know Reaper has those soul
Globes laying around the map what is the
sort of science or magic behind those
and I know this is kind of a weird
answer to give but in some cases we want
things to just exist for gameplay
reasons that don't necessarily need to
be supported by lore in the game so not
everything is explained as canon lore
when you're playing 6v6
overwatch that might happen in the game
that's why you can have a tracer and
Widowmaker on the same team even though
they don't like each other and they're
fighting against another tracer and
Widowmaker river asks what if I broke my
overwatch disc in half I hope you have
overwatch installed if you're playing on
PC you can just redownload overwatch you
can buy five new computers and
redownload overwatch and we've got your
licence on hand now if you're playing on
the Xbox or the PlayStation you're going
to be in trouble and you're going to
have a hard time playing overwatch
without that disc glitter guts writes to
us how come I'm not good at overwatch
I've played for I
think 200 hours so uh to
glitter guts I I think sometimes we
really miss judge ourselves as players a
lot of players think they are much
better than they actually are and I
think there's a whole group of players
who are way better than they think they
are and I'm not sure which you are but
I'm sure if we tracked your play style
and we went back and looked through your
play history I'm willing to bet that
you've gotten much smarter and much
better at the game as time has gone on
one thing that's very challenging about
a game like overwatch is that its player
versus player only so as you're evolving
and getting better the matchmaker is
consistently putting you against players
of your skill so they're also getting
better and what that means is in a game
that's player versus environment only
where you're fighting a I control
creatures you'll get to the point where
you'll just sort of stomp them and in
overwatch you're never really going to
get to that point against other players
from kettle hello this might be a stupid
question but will I trigger overwatch is
cheat detection if I download mods for
other games so no you should not trigger
any sort of cheat detection if you're
downloading legitimate mods for for
legitimate games that have you know mod
support it won't trigger any sort of
cheek detection for overwatch Emily
Heredia asks how do the overwatch heroes
feel about pineapple on pizza we've
talked many times about the diversity of
overwatch heroes and what rich cast it
is right now we have 24 heroes and they
come from all walks of life they have
completely different backstories they
play completely differently they care
about different things the really
interesting thing about the overwatch
heroes is that the only common thing
that they have is that they all like
pineapple on pizza Carrie Sloane writes
to us I'm curious why the map is payload
theme but Hana Mora isn't a payload map
and overwatch what made you decide to
make that choice this is a question
about the map that was recently added to
heroes of the storm where they added a
Hana Mora map that takes place in in
Hana Mora but isn't the same as the
overwatch map and I think this is one of
the awesome things about heroes of the
storm and overwatch and how they can
coexist in the same universe that you
know a hot
or is a big place so there's room for
assault maps and there's room for
payload maps and also sort of showcases
the differences between the two games
and how they can play differently and
make different design and gameplay
choices to really feature and showcase
the best parts of how the heroes in both
games play David Jones
why doesn't quick play have the ability
to tell if we will be switching sides
next game or not quick play if you're
playing any of our game-mode types with
the exception of control you will always
switch sides in quick play now sometimes
a match will collapse because players
leaving at the end of a round and the
matchmaker will be forced to create a
new match and this might give the
impression that we're not always
switching sides every time but as long
as a critical mass of players stays
together and or the matchmaker can
backfill in time you'll always get a
mirror match in quick play from Joseph
Edwards can I ask a question about
overwatch why is over time in the game
originally overtime wasn't in overwatch
and we were playing a lot of matches
without it and it was extremely
frustrating to us because as a team
you're sometimes doing a final push in
particular when you're on attack and you
might be right on the control point and
feel like you're coming out ahead on a
team battle and you're about to win it
and then time would just run out and the
match would be over and it felt very
unsatisfying and very unfair over time
we have played with many different
mechanics to make the overtime period
feel more fair and I currently think
we're in a pretty good place with
overtime from Lea hi I was just
wondering and I'm sure this question is
kind of annoying it's not don't worry we
get lots of questions will overwatch be
coming to Mack is it definite answer I
would not say that it's definite always
out of the question we will never be on
Mac we are open-minded to it we just
sort of need the priorities of our
development process to line up with the
capabilities of the platform in order
for it to become a reality
Millenia maile ot may be stupid question
but how can I see my national rank in
overwatch you currently cannot see
anything like a national ring
in overwatch it doesn't really exist
that way what we have in overwatch is a
top 500 system that's regional base and
we currently have three main regions we
have Americas which includes North
America South America and Australia we
have Asia and we have Europe China also
has a separate region unto itself we
don't have anything that's on a
country-by-country basis and we also
only track rank for the top 500 players
from the game you two'll and its
trademark why does everyone HC Roadhog
as a big sweetie when the lord
literally describes him as cruel and
sadistic what's fun about overwatch and
the characters is that they belong to
you guys and you can do whatever you
want with them so we often see shipping
different characters that we normally
hadn't thought of having romantic
relationships and we think that's
awesome we see you taking different
takes on them you've turned 76 into a
dad you've turned diva into some sort of
mountain dew chugging gremlin we think
it's awesome if that's what makes the
game cool to you guys it makes you love
the characters even more go for it is
what we say Megan LM anime how do I
enter the World Cup for overwatch so in
some ways you're entered for the World
Cup just by playing first off 32
countries are going to qualify and the
way that they qualifies we're looking at
the top players and their average skill
rating across all nations and and we're
tracking that it's on our website you
can look at it so if you are one of the
top players in your country there will
be a selection committee that will be
reaching out to you if they think you
will be world cup worthy Michelle lega
how do I politely tell my roommate to
get off my ps4 so I can play some
overwatch I have two answers to this one
the first one is I'm going to make up a
name for your roommate it's Mabel Mabel
would you be so kind as to leave the ps4
for a few minutes if not hours so I can
indulge in some overwatch that's that's
one and then the second one is a little
bit easier you say to Mabel did you hear
that I think somebody's at the door
and then she gets up and she goes to the
door then you quickly lock the door that
the ps4 is in and then you lock her out
and then you just start playing
overwatch so it's up to you
Liam Jack boo
i'ts what do I do if this comes up I
think it's funny that we say unexpected
server error as if there's like an
expected server error that we would pop
a screen up for but in this case just
try to log in again if the game does not
allow you to log in again what I
recommend doing is going to play
overwatch comm then going to the
community section and looking for our
tech support forum and checking if the
CS representative has posted like a
server status update you could also go
to the Blizzard CS Twitter account and
ask them is something wrong with the
overwatch servers and will try to
respond as quickly as possible
Charles Clausen why doesn't Blizzard
help the smaller team out to even the
playing field
10% health or low-level BOTS we have not
been believers in catch-up mechanics
they tend in our opinion to feel a
little bit unfair for the team who's
doing well and it gives you that sense
of futility if you're performing really
well and the other team gets sort of
this free boost to bring you up to par
it tends to feel really bad for the team
who's doing well in the first place if
there was a mismatch for whatever reason
and the teams were not fair or even
believe it or not I'd rather have there
be an acceleration to defeat and then
the matchmaker split up the match and
find a new better match odds solo whoa
whoa whoa
they don't keep track of kills in
skirmish anymore how can I prove I'm
king of the skirmish now I actually
didn't know that I have had skirmish
turned off for a long time I used to
engage in skirmish all the time when I
was in the matchmaking queue and then
recently I turned it off because of the
people that I've been grouping with
didn't like to have it on so I will look
into that I think that's actually pretty
valid I mean the kill count doesn't
really mean much because in essence
there's no match going on and people are
in for different times but will still
look into that Betina asks us but the
question is can I get away with playing
overwatch at work absolutely I recommend
going to the careers at Blizzard comm
page so far all of us have gotten away
with playing tons of overwatch at work
and I've only gotten a couple talking to
use about it and I still have a job so
it really depends on your workplace from
cat boy cat girl how come in on his old
overwatch skin she looks young
but mercy and Genji and McCree look
exactly the same how have they not aged
at all so aging and overwatch is sort of
interesting because you have characters
like Mei who is literally in a
cryofreeze like Mei is one of the older
characters but because she was in that
cryofreeze for some time she's aged at a
different rate tracer had her accident
on the slipstream and that's caused her
to have some unique aging properties as
well with mercy you have to keep in mind
that she is one of the highest tech
doctors in existence and she has
extremely advanced medical technology
and with that you need to remember that
mercy also helped Genji greatly in his
recovery and helped him get over his
Grievous wounds that he received from
Hanzo there's a little bit of Mercy
Medical magic going on with both of them
Micah writes to us I just want to play
overwatch why does it take years to find
a match if you are an extremely high
skilled player the matchmaker will take
a longer time finding a match for you
because it doesn't want to subject lower
skill players to your inevitable wrath
so if you're very high skill player it's
going to take you a longer time
especially in competitive mode Josh
Brown how does this guy keep putting out
stuff like this and this is an amazing
video it's by a gentleman by the name of
Dino flask he's become quite a legend
dino flask keeps putting out amazing
content mostly by the talent that he has
recruited to be in his videos and he
works with a wickedly talented group of
individuals I mean when you think about
like acting and performing talent it's
no wonder that this guy is making
amazing videos the talent is really
carrying the videos for him